mr. Arbuckle thank you for coming in I
have Garfield's test results oh great
how's he looking not so great actually
surely mr. Arbuckle you've noticed that
your cat is morbidly obese I mean maybe
he's a little pudgy he's 40 pounds
overweight that's that's like for cats
what have you been feeding him well just
the usual stuff water uh cat food
lasagna Fancy Feast I'm sorry what was
that last one
fancy fees no the one before Fancy Feast
lasagna yes lasagna yeah yeah yeah I I
feed Garfield lasagna you you feed you
oh you mean like a little nibble when
he's bothering you at the dinner table
oh no I will bake him an entire tray of
lasagna and feed it to him you prepare
and bake an entire tray of lasagna for
your cat to eat oh yeah and brother does
he love it he skips it up with his
little hands like no no no minimum like
I'm talking like four or five seconds an
entire tray mm-hmm and just to be
perfectly clear on this this isn't a
type of special cat food lasagna you're
feeding him pasta beef cheese three
kinds of cheese cats do not eat cheese
mr. Arbuckle they're carnivores what yes
listen to me you're going to kill your
cat if you keep feeding him entire trays
of lasagna he is going to die do you
understand I think so art are you
recommending I put him to sleep
what no I'm just saying you should stop
serving your cat full trays of hearty
Italian food like grandma used to make
he's a cat not a family of five at Buca
di Beppo but he's always talking to me
about how much he loves lasagna what
what was that he's always talking to me
about how much he loves lasagna I mean
he goes on and on
okay uh what do you and your cat
Garfield talk about oh we talk about
everything
loneliness trouble at work my problems
with women I am free this weekend by the
way
you you get advice on your love life
from your overweight tabby cat actually
Garfield's not that helpful he usually
just makes fun of me what a rascal look
at him
oh wow okay uh mr. Arbuckle here's what
I'm going to do I'm gonna write you a
prescription for a low-calorie cat food
for Garfield okay and an anti-psychotic
for you Oh technically they're for dogs
but they should do the trick until you
get some real psychiatric help my dog's
name
Odie he's dumb which I recommend you
seek immediately dumb dog falling off
the counter crash okay one last thing
I'd like to schedule a follow-up for
Garfield house next Monday
oh I don't think that's gonna work for
him he hates Mondays
tell him Garfield Oh Garfield that was a
good one
Cheryl call security